I heard you can hear Jupiter's magnetic
field when you turn on the radio it that
true one of my predecessors discovered
the radio emission from Jupiter he put
up a a a a radio receiver for the press
and so you could hear these this sort of
radio static but it was you knew it was
Jupiter the headline later was
astronomers hear sounds from Jupiter and
it's like no no radio waves right we
just happen to have very convenient ways
of turning radio waves into sound but
what it is is electromagnetic energy
in the form of radio waves and what what
exactly did it sound like hey welcome to
wj-u-p-tr that's right we're coming at
you with no no it's it's j-o-v-e I do
yes
um yeah I don't know does Jupiter have a
smooth radio voice yeah just like let me
try let me try
this is j-o-v-e